Poonam her husband Shambhu and their son
Mythili SH live a simple life untouched
by the 21st century
[Music]
but when Poonam became pregnant with her
second child everything changed
[Music]
before she was born I had a dream that I
had to make a temple to Lakshmi Lakshmi
is the Hindu goddess of wealth and
fortune her many limbs symbolize
righteousness desire wealth and
liberation this goddess of good luck is
celebrated in the month of October the
same month that Poonam gives birth to
her baby girl when I first saw her it
was so upsetting that I fainted for two
days she has four arms and four legs she
looks like Lakshmi the goddess came
under her own name in this remote part
of India health care is hard to come by
disabled infants are often left in the
fields to die but Lakshmi is lucky the
villagers know she's special
the second they see her after she was
born for a whole month crowds of people
came to see her it was said that Laxmi
love had been born here news of the
incarnation of the goddess lakshmi
spreads quickly from the remote district
of auroria it travels a thousand miles
to the heart of modern India Bangalore
is one of India's
technologically-advanced
and sparsh Hospital is where top
orthopedic surgeon dr. Sharon Cottle
first learns of Lakshmi Tama a girl with
eight limbs
photos of the two-year-old present a
medical challenge unlike any he's ever
seen and he immediately decides to help
[Music]
namaste that's me sitting since a while
technically watch me we'll have her
first medical exam she reacts like any
girl or age
protesting loudly to the poking and
prodding
Lakshmi has two arms and two legs that
function normally
the uppermost limbs on each side of her
body
but below them in mirror-image are two
more sets of arms and legs that belong
to Lakshmi's parasitic twin an unformed
being with no head
dr. patel's exam confirms his initial
impression Lakshmi's parasitic twin
should be surgically removed but such a
complex operation has never been
attempted in India before Poonam and
Shambhu faced a difficult decision leave
life as they know it behind four
potentially life-threatening endeavor or
keep their little girl as they have
always known her as Lakshmi the goddess
were they loved